AND THE OILERS.  FLURNTION OUT,E
FRONT, BLOCKED AWAYIS
RIGHT, BUT THE SHOP CAME TO HIS
LEFT, AND HE HADPLE OF
SITUATIONS THERE NOW.
ONE OF THE BEST HE MISSES.
2.40 LEFT
FRONT, BUT GO.
NUGENT HOPKINS DOWN THE MIDDLE
OF THE GLOVE SAVED BY PETER SB.
>> WE'LL TAKE A LACK
MCDAVID TO DRAISAITL CORNER, BRN
BATSALS AGAINSTN PASS, DOUGHTY S
HACK
BUT YOU KNOW -- HAD TO KILL THE
DOUBLE MINOR, DID THAT, NOWOWL .
LEMIEUX X L SAY -- THAT'S THE ST
CREATED THE PROBLEMS FOR THE
BODY IN THE W W HERE. IT COVER
HE'S GOING TO GO AFTER
TURNOVER, ONE OF THOSE THINGS
THAT JUST HURTS YOU, ESPECIALLY
AGAINST MCDAVID AND HISIS TIED O
STAYED IN, ON THE LINE.
DOUG MORING.
SECOND PLAY IN A ROW...
AND THECT THERE, BUT
AGAIN, LOOSE PUCK SITUATION.
IT'S NOT LIKEHE FIRST PASS, BUT
TIP. I DO YOU SEE
GET IT IN.
PUT SOME PRESSURE ON THE D.
BUT THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN KINGS..
THIS BLIND TALKSKS A SHOT BROKE,
STICK FROM SMITH, KEMPE JAMMING
FOR THE PUCK.
LOOSE AT THE SIG IT.
AND LIZOTTE LOSES OUT.